NGGEORGIA REPUBLICANIE TAYLOR G
NO SGEERSY, AND YET EVEN NOWE F
EMBR KNOWLEDGE
OF U.S. GEOGPHY AND HISTORAFTE
LOVEUR CELIEVE WS,ERSON,
S SHOULD
GO FOR
WH TIDDLE
EA,
I, SE.
GUAM IS NOA FOIGY.
IT IS A U.S.TORY, AN
HAS EN 1898.ORTHE AR
BELIEVE. OE U.S.ENS, AGN NATIONS
TO MAKATOINT ON ,
GUAM'S LDEN CORE
VISITED GREENE'S CONOFFICE A HEL
HEF COOKIES HED TO THE
SHS  BUT
ANIDHE
SERVICE MEMBERS.
>>HASO MUCH FOR
AT YOU DO.Y APPRECTEANK YOU GUY
SAFE.
THRESSWO MUTOWLOF YOU AND SA
HI AND TELL YOU HOW MUCH S TES
YOU GUYS DO.
>>NIE NOIS
NICOLAS.E OF G
THANK YOU,GRESSMAN, FOR TH UK
AB.
RSTAND THAT YOU
WANTED TO MAKE A POINT HERE AND
THAT OF Y
IMPORTANT TOR CONSTITUENTS
THAT GUAM IS
RICANS, AND THAT IS
CERTAINLY NOT IN DOUBTR T  IN D.
I R R SUPPORTERS, I'M SUREHAVE T
WOK T Y OF
THGATIVE
D BEE FO
SEE ATT T OF THIS GROUTH CGR
ALL,CT
WE WERE TAKING O GEN O
A TOURTHTOL.
WE ACTUALLY VILE .ELIVERED -- WT
VER COOKIES TO CONGRESSWOMAN
GREE DELIVERED A D
CHKER SPEAKER'S TO OUR MAJORITY.
IS MAIRD ONI' ONORED TET
CONGRESS AND WE WE
L TO MEENE WE WEE  MEE
MAJORITY WHIP CLYBURN AND ATA R
THEM.
ASE, Y
UNDERSTAND YOU WENT TO CLY'S
OFFICE, BUT S
FROM CIVILIA O GETTING LM T THIT
YOU, AN , USINS E IT 'S CO
ASWHAT DO YOU TO
IS UNFOUNDED.WE WERE NOT AT A U
MILITARY SERVICE MEMBERS FOR
L PROPS.I  MY GUARDSME ATOUR OF
STOPPED BY SEVERAL MEMBERS
OFFICES ANDELIRE
ODIES.
ROP ANNEITSH O MY BUT ODWILL ISG
WE WISH TO GUAM TOERUARDSMEN WI
END THE SAME AND WERE VERY
E ABLETATE
THAT.RE AWAREF NGHE
AMERICAN SAMOA RNTATIVESBERS WHT
RS OF THE MILITARY OR
AS BEFORE, WTAIPLE TOURS.I WAS
HIGH-RANKING GUARDSMEN IN MY
OFFICE Y KNOW, WE LY
SHOULDN'T BEKI -- ERE'UESTION.W
OU?
THAT'S REALLY TH
TH
THIS DOES PUT THEM IN A TOUG
I HEAR YOU'RE  IT DOESN'T,S.Y G
ACTIONS WE'VE TAKEN. VERY VE
AM GOO
ERIVERIN
TO Y D I THTHS A
VERYDOHEN CERTAIN MEMBERS
ITGUGOAT OUTREY
THAT'S A VERDO AND I'M VER  CNT
ASE SPEAK.METHING THAT
BE MORE CONCERNED E'RE
AREAN L
1521 WAS WHEN GUAM BECAME A
ND W TO BE AN
THEY ARE UNABL VOTE R AVE GUDS N
ESS TO VOTETHR AND THEY'RE
LE FORORAL
COLLEGE REPRESENTATION TO ELECT.
SHNG
HOE WECANS I
ABLE TT THE PEOPLE WHO
D
I THINK ATNG
COOKIES AND GOING AND SALLOT
LET'TASE MEN
THESE WOMEPUR LIVE THE LINE ANMM
WE LOST COLAS CLAN IN AFGHANISTT
STATES,RI NA A PEOPLEVERYTEBID
THE LE M
INK THSO THANKR FAMILY, ORTSCE.
AMERICANS WOULD SHARIN SEE THAT.
ALL THE D
ABOUT, I THINK THOSEINCRED IDIST
WHY PU IN THISION?MEAN,
HETS WHO
MI UNIQUE POSITIONNOT , THE
TH D F THAT IT HASEMENDOUS ESTM
AS APOLITICAL.WH A
POTICAL  LIKE THIS WHERE THERE L
NEGATIVE EFFECTS, THAT
S PUT TO THE BASKET OF
USING THE MILITARY IN A
POLITIWAY, WHETHER IT'S THE
ON STH
SOMETHING, YOU KNOW, THE DYOUR A
POTITHE MIOU TAKE ANY OF
AKY OF TT
CRITICISM AND THINK PERHAPS
ABOUT HIS MOMENT IS BEYOND
?
IAV
EVENT HEARY.T THINYB
GOING OUT AND CALLING THEMSELVES
AN EXPERT ANN BEHALF
OF THEARY.IN
G TO DISRN ON THEIR --
>> THEY 'T.JUSTANE
MILITARY.
>> RIGHT.
ON BF OFCIVILIRELATIONS.
>> I WOULD ENCOURAGEPL LOOK AVIA
GREATER THAN IT IS IS NOT
OUBSOLUT
GUARDSMEAND NOT
SPREADING GOODWILL AND DELIVERIC
YOI
TH
TO BTALKINOUT
COMES TO GUAM.
WHCOMES TOERVICEMEMBERS.ME SACR
THEY'RE MAKING FOR TY
E SACRIFES
UNDERREPRESENTED.
BUT ARE MILI I
GIVING MY ARDSMEN A TOUR.
ACTUALLY THAT STATT IS VER
LEADERSHACHOGOARY'S GOING TO
LOOKT,E IT BECAUSE THE W TELY N
POLITION WHATSOEVER.
>> DELEGATE,